my taste has changed throughout the
years when I first saw uh a model 3
Tesla I thought it was the most hideous
car without the gorillas like this is so
stupid it took me all but two months to
think that it was one of the coolest
looking cars same with cyber truck I'm
mourned cyber truck when I first saw
that thing I was at that that thing with
and I went with uh we used to do a
podcast called our ludicrous future so
we talked a lot about like you know cars
and EVs and stuff we went to that
unveiling and literally like we had like
almost a non-alcohol-induced hangover
the next morning of like morning the
hideousness of cyber truck
come six months later a year later and
I'm like damn it that thing's actually
kind of cool yeah that also teaches you
just something about again it's the
thing you said uh earlier sort of uh
going against
the the current of the experts of the
beliefs or whatever is and and making a
decision from first principles some of
that also applies to design and styling
and fashion and culture and all big time
uh some of that you know so fashion
especially is so interesting so being
rebellious
against the current the the current fads
actually is the way to pave
the new fads well it didn't take long
for others to follow you look at like
currently like what Hyundai is doing
with their I forget which one like the
ionic or something like that it's it's
Square it's like it's boxy you know it's
a throwback it's 80s it's got these
beautiful retro tail lights it's got
these Square headlights it's it's it's
very inspired by cyber truck in my
opinion I mean it might not be it might
be coincidental that we're all kind of
getting this feature Vibe but uh I
personally like the boxy so I never I
still haven't understood uh Porsches
Porsches I still can't quite understand
the small size the elegant that the
curves I don't I don't quite get it like
I said I don't love the look of the RX7
I don't love it but I love it because of
the engineering I guess that it
represents you know what I mean yeah
it's it's uh it's not the surface stuff
it's the deep down stuff it's that 50 50
weight distribution that matters